The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RYAN ALEXANDER: All right, so
as this XKCD comic points out,
in CS, it can be very
difficult to figure out
when something is
just really hard
or something is
virtually impossible.
And until a couple
years ago, people
thought this idea of
image classification
would be something that was
closer to the impossible side.
But with the advent of
deep learning typology,
we've made significant strides
in image classification,
and now the problem's
actually quite practical.
So today we'll be
going through how
the process of
image classification
with deep learning works.
So we're first going to talk
about what deep learning is,
and then we'll move into some of
the image processing techniques
that researchers use,
followed by the architecture
of the convolutional
neural networks,
which will be the main
focus in our presentation.
We'll also talk about
the training process,
and then go through some
results and limitations of CNNs
and image classification.
So what is deep learning?
Well, the term is
particularly vague,
and it's purposely so
for a couple of reasons.
The first is mystery is
always good for marketing.
But the second reason
is that deep learning
refers to a pretty wide range
of machine learning algorithms.
They do have some commonalities.
They all seek to solve
problems of a complexity
that previously, people thought
only people could solve.
So these are more sophisticated
classification problems
than traditional
conventional machine learning
algorithms can do.
So how do they go
about doing this?
Well, all of these
deep learning programs
tend to take all the
processes that need
to happen, and split them up.
They've got different parts
of their program working
on different things, all
while performing calculations,
and then at the end,
it all comes together,
and we get a result.
Of course, this
isn't unique to deep learning,
and lots of distributed systems
decentralize their calculations.
But the key thing
about deep learning
is that every part is
performing these calculations.
The calculations are
not simple calculations.
They're not we'll do this
one simple operation over,
and over again on a lot
of data, and then we'll
get a result at the end.
Each part is performing some
particularly complicated
process on all the little parts
before they come together.
So why is this
architecture a good idea?
Why did engineers
come up with this sort
of decentralized,
multi-layered complex process?
Well, we take the example
of image classification.
It turns out that
the human brain
does a pretty similar process.
So here's the human
visual system,
and it's pretty much a
hierarchical process.
So you begin by
moving from the retina
into the first
areas of the brain,
and as the information
gets processed,
it moves from one region
of the brain to the other,
and each spatial
element of your brain
is performing an entirely
different calculation.
For example, the
v1 area over here
is picking out
edges and corners,
and then over here, a
couple steps later in v4,
you're starting to group
those figures together.
And so the brain
kind of operates
in a way that is very similar to
the way these networks operate.
So let's talk about
to classify a face.
If I asked you guys how
would you classify a face,
what is the first
thing you might do?
Well, as I mentioned before,
the first thing out brain
does is it finds these edges.
The first thing to do is
identify where the face
is versus everything else.
Now, does anyone have
any idea as to what
we could with the next step?
Julian, you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you could
group these edges together.
RYAN ALEXANDER: Right.
We could maybe identify
some of these features
that we're working with.
So these are things like
noses, and lips, and eyes.
And then what do we do after we
have these individual features?
Steve.
AUDIENCE: Well, maybe we can
group some of those together.
RYAN ALEXANDER: Exactly.
Yeah, we can organize them into
what we know the pattern to be.
We know that a face has to
have two eyes, above a nose,
and then above the mouth.
So that is precisely what a
neural network actually ends up
doing, and we'll walk through
the process of how it does this
later on in the talk.
But as you can see,
the intuitive way
that we classify a
face, and the way
our brains are
wired to do it, is
pretty similar to the way
got these neural networks
to operate.
So like I said,
we're talking a lot
about these convolutional
neural networks.
There are other types of
architectures involved.
Like we mentioned
before, deep learning
is a pretty wide
variety of algorithms,
but we're going to
focus on these CNNs.
To give you a precursor
of how good these CNN are,
this results from
ImageNet competition.
So the ImageNet
competition is basically
exactly what it sounds like,
a bunch of computer scientists
get together, and see how
many images they can correctly
classify.
And their error rate
was pretty high.
Almost a third error
rate over here in 2010,
2011, and then in 2011, the CNNs
were introduced to the topic,
and the error rate plummeted.
As you can see
over here in 2015,
we've got a significant
improvement in these ImageNet
competitions.
So clearly, the CNNs
have been very effective,
and it's definitely
been something
that is exciting in the field
and happening right now.
All right, so now we're going
to move into image processing.
ISHWARYA ANANTHABHOTLA:
OK, so Ryan gave us
a nice overview of where
we get this concept
of neural networks, but
let's take a time travel,
and go into a quick
history lesson.
So suppose I had a chair,
and I wanted the computer
to classify this chair.
I have some a priori knowledge
about what sort of things
make up a chair.
So I might be
interested in looking
at arms, and corners of the
chair, legs, things like that.
So I would go ahead, and feature
engineer my discovery scheme
to be looking for
specific things.
So I'm going to talk
about some techniques that
are traditionally used.
For example, chairs, doors,
these things have corners.
So I might use an image
processing technique called
a Harris Corner Detector,
where we basically
look at large changes in
intensity as groups of pixels
move from an image to
an image that indicate
the presence of corners, and you
can use common corners to say
that OK, all of these images are
chairs, or doors, or whatever.
Similarly, I want to say I have
a bunch of pictures of chairs
of different sizes, but
that they all must have
so many corners or something.
So typically, we use a sift
algorithm to scale invariant
feature transforms.
It basically says that
across different sizes,
I still should be able
to extract information
about the placement of corners.
Another common technique
that's used in image processing
is what we call HOG,
Histogram of Gradients.
So basically, for
example, in this image,
if I want to say I want to find
all the images that have faces
in them, or consist
of faces, let's
say, I might come up with
a template of a face that
basically assigns gradients
to groups of pixels that form
an outline of what
looks like a face,
and then scan it across my
sample images, and say OK,
a face is present in this image.
Obviously, there
are some errors.
A mead cap, and a logo back
here have become a face,
but this is the
traditional approach.
But here's the problem,
what if I don't actually
necessarily know what features
are the most critical depending
on the dataset that I get?
I want the system
itself to figure out
what techniques to apply without
having any a priori knowledge
about the dataset.
So this is exactly
the idea of CNNs,
the convolutional
neural networks.
We want the techniques to
be learned automatically
by the process, by the system.
So if I'm trying
to classify faces,
I want the system to
figure out that eyes,
and ears, and nose, these are
the most important things.
Or if I'm trying to
classify elephants,
the ears and trunks are
the critical features,
without me having
to say OK, we're
going to do corner detection,
so on, and so forth.
So this is the idea.
So to be able to understand
this process in greater detail,
I'm first going to go
into a little bit of math,
and the idea is to present
the most fundamental operation
here, which is the convolution.
So this is the formal definition
of the two-dimensional
convolution, and since
we're working with images,
we're only considering
the two-dimensional case.
So in a more graphical
presentation,
which is a little bit easier
to understand than just seeing
the formula, the
idea is that we have
a kernel, or a
convolutional filter
that we seek to apply
on another image,
and that extracts some
information about that image
that we can use to help us
classify the convolution.
So assume that this is our
kernel, or this is our filter,
and suppose this--
oh, there it is.
So suppose we're applying
the kernel [INAUDIBLE]
here to the image
that's in green.
So the idea is we want to slide
this filter across the image,
and what we're
basically doing this is
a succession of dot products.
So at each placement
on the image,
we multiply the
overlayed numbers,
and the sum becomes the output
image on the convolt output.
So this is basically the
way the process works.
You probably notice that there's
a reduction in dimension,
and Henry will talk a little
bit more about why this is.
Let me get to it, and
then [INAUDIBLE] So let's
see some examples
of what information
we get by applying
the convolution.
So you see the image of
a tiger on the top left.
When we apply a filter
that's a low pass filter,
basically-- it's
a Gaussian-- then
we get low spatial frequency
information about this image.
So basically, we blurred
it, and this tells us
something specific that
we might want to learn.
So the kernel actually looks
like a two-dimensional Gaussian
function that's been distributed
across this three-by-three
kernel.
Similarly, we
might be interested
in high spatial
frequency information.
So in this case, we're
looking at sharp features.
So horizontal edges
or vertical edges.
So a question for you is
if I have this kernel,
which of these outputs
when this kernel
was applied to the original
image, which of these outputs
do you think it produced?
AUDIENCE: The third
one on the right.
ISHWARYA ANANTHABHOTLA:
Yeah, that's exactly right,
and it's probably
pretty easy to see
why that's the case, given
that the numbers are all
horizontal bands here.
Lastly, we also may be
interested in extracting
information at a
particular frequency.
So we can take the
difference of a high pass
filter and a low pass
filter, and add it
to your frequency you can
extract information about that
as well.
OK, one last helpful
piece of information
is that there's
another way that you
can think of the information
that's learned at each stage
because a convolution
can also be
thought of as a Fourier
transform in the frequency
domain.
You can think of the image
transformation that way.
So from an image perspective,
what a Fourier transform is
is basically a sum of a
set of sinusoidal gratings
that differ, say, in frequency,
in orientation, in amplitude,
and in phase.
So you can think about
the zebra image here
that's actually a composite
of different gradients
that might look like this,
and the Fourier coefficients
would be how much of
each of these pieces
come together to make
that final image.
So just to get a sense of
what kind of information
this could convey, we typically
take a Fourier transformation,
and break it apart into
the magnitude and phase
representation.
So you see magnitude,
and you see phase.
So those images weren't
particularly clear,
but this is a really
good example for this.
So if we take the
Fourier transform
of all the horizontal
text here, you
see how the magnitude
reflects this,
and you can go back to
the math to understand
why it's reflected in
a vertical marking.
And similarly, if I were
to take that same image,
and rotate it, and then ask
for the Fourier transform,
you see how that information
is contained very clearly
in the magnitude spectrum.
So these might be things
that a network would
learn at each stage to try
to identify this as a text,
or as as body of text that's
tilted one way or the other,
so on and so forth.
So with that, we can now go into
what the actual architecture
of a convolutional neural is.
HENRY NASSIF: All right, so as
it was said earlier, in order
to classify or detect
objects, you actually
need certain features.
You need to be able to
identify these features.
And the way you can
identify these features
is using certain convolutions
or certain filters.
In many cases, we don't know
what these features are,
and as a result of
that, we don't actually
know what the filters are
to extract these features.
And what convolution neural
networks allow us to do
is actually determine
what these features are,
and also determine what
the filters are in order
to extract these features.
Now, the idea for
convolutional neural networks,
or the idea for replicating
how the brain works
started in about 1960s or
1950s after some experiments
by Hubel and Wesel.
And what happened in
these experiments,
as can be seen here,
is a cat was actually
shown a light band
at different angles,
and the neural
activity of the cat
was measured using an electrode.
And the outcome
from this experiment
show that based on the angle
at which the light was shown,
the neural response of
the cat was different.
As you can see here, the
number of neurons, as well as
the neurons that were
firing were very different
based on the angle.
So what you can see
also here is really
a plot of the response versus
the orientation of the light.
And what this has led
Hubel and Wesel to
is the idea that
neurons in the brain
are organized in a certain
topographical order,
and at each filter, it
fills a specific role,
and the only fires when its
specific input is shown,
or when the angle is show,
or the angle is specified.
Now, the first step to
actually replicating
how the brain works
in code is really
understanding how the building
block, the neuron, works.
That's a quick
reminder of 7012 here.
So a neuron is actually a cell
with dendrites, nucleus, axon,
and a terminal.
And what the neuron
actually does
is aggregate the action
potentials or the inputs
it gets from all the
neighboring neurons that
are connected to it
through the timelines,
and it sums these action
potentials, and then compares
them to a certain threshold
that it has internally,
and that would determine
whether or not this neuron would
fire an action potential.
And that very simple idea can
actually be replicated in code.
An artificial neuron looks
very much like a natural one.
So what you would have
is a set of inputs.
Here we have three inputs that
are summed inside of a cell,
or a neuron.
The sum here is not
just a regular sum,
it's a weighted sum.
So the neuron
specifies some weight,
which you can think of as how
much it values the input coming
from a specific neuron, and
then the input is multiplied
by its weight, and then the
total sum that the neuron
computes is then fed into
an activation function that
produces the output that the
neuron then basically produces.
Now, what we just saw here
is really a simple neuron,
a single neuron.
You can't really do much
with just one neuron,
so what you would do is
combined these neurons
in a certain topography,
or in that case,
we have a network with
seven neurons organized
in three different layers.
And what you can think
of that is really
as one big neuron with 12
inputs, and one output.
So for example, in the
case of the chair that
was previously
mentioned, if you're
trying to identify whether
a specific image has
a chair in it or not,
these 12 inputs here
could be some sub images,
or some small areas
of the initial image that
you feed into the network,
and the output here
could be a yes or no.
Whether the image has a chair,
or doesn't have a chair.
And that is really
the concept behind
convolutional neural
networks, which
we'll go into details in a bit.
So what each neuron would
be doing in that case,
is really just
performing a dot product,
which if you aggregate
that with the dot
products computed by each
of the other neurons,
you would obtain a convolution.
So what we have here
is three inputs.
If the input, in that case,
is an image or a sub image,
then the inputs would be pixels.
The weights that you
would be using here
would be the filter weights,
which is the filter that you
use in the convolution.
And then the sum here
would be the dot product
of the weights and the
inputs, and that sum
would be computed by a specific
neuron in your network.
Then, that would be
the convolution step,
and then that
convolution step would
happen at the first
layer in the network.
So you would be applying
this to the input,
but you also would
be applying this
at the second layer,
and third layer.
In that case, we're
only showing what
happens in the first layer.
The next step after
the convolution
would be the activation step.
So the dot product
computed here would
be there's a function that
would be applied to the sum,
and then that
function would produce
the output of the neuron.
And this is where the
activation layer is.
You also have another
activation layer here,
and then a final one here.
What we just went through
now are convolutions
and activations, but this is
not the only thing that actually
happens in a neural net.
What we also have is a step
called subsampling, which
we will be talking about next.
For now, we will dig
deeper into the activation,
and specifically, what
activation functions to use.
In that case, we can see
that that's a neuron,
and what the neuron
is doing here
is the weighted sum
that we talked about,
or the dot product.
And then the output
from this would
be fed into a certain
activation function.
Common activation functions
are sigmoid, tanh,
or rectify linear unit, and
we will go through each one
independently.
So here, we can see the
sigmoid activation function.
So what this function
essentially does
is map any input to an output
in the range of zero to one,
and it's defined as one divided
by one plus e to the minus x.
The other common activation
function is tanh,
and that's any
input to an output
between minus one and one.
And then finally, would be the
rectified linear unit, which
maps an input to itself
if it's positive,
or to zero if it's negative.
Now, in theory, you
could use any function
as an activation
function in your network,
but that's not what you
want to do in practice.
You want your
activation functions
to be non-linear
for one main reason,
that the goal of the
activation function
is actually to introduce
non-linearity in your system.
And if all your activation
functions are linear,
then you would essentially be
having a linear system, which
prevents you from achieving
the level of complexity
that you would ideally want to
achieve with a neural network.
And there's a formal
proof for as to why
you need non-linear
activation functions.
They don't all need
to be non-linear,
but you need to have a least
a few non-linear activation
functions in your network.
And the proof is available
in the appendix, or the link
to the paper that has the proof.
So after we've discussed what
happens at the activation
layer, now we want to
talk about convolution.
So as I said earlier,
an image is obviously
a two-dimensional image,
but we're using RGB images.
So actually need three channels.
So what this means is
that an image is actually
three-dimensional, and each 2D
matrix represents one channel.
One of them corresponding to R,
one of them corresponding to G,
one of them corresponding
to B. So a 32 by 32 image
would essentially be represented
by a 32 by 32 by three matrix,
as can be seen here.
So what happens at
the convolution layer?
So here we have a
nice animation that
shows what is happening at
each convolutional layer.
So assume we have a five
by five by three filter.
So what this is,
essentially, would
be doing is covering a certain
patch in the original image,
which is 32 by 32 by three.
So what can see here
is that for that five
by five by three patch
in the original image,
we have a neuron
that is actually
performing the dot
product on all the pixels
in that specific patch.
So what is happening
here is the pixel values,
which in that case, we have
five by five by three pixels,
are being multiplied
by the filter values,
and this operation is
being performed here.
Then, after that dot
product is performed,
it's fed into an activation
function, as can be seen here,
and this produces the
output of this neuron.
Now, this is what this single
neuron is actually doing.
It's just covering that
area of the original image.
What you would have
in a neural net
is many neurons, each
covering a certain area
of the original image.
And if you aggregate the output
of all of these neurons, what
you would be doing or performing
is, essentially, a convolution
on the original image.
And to formalize
what happens here,
or what's the output
that's being produced
from that operation, we can
look at that from a more
mathematical perspective.
So if you have an
input of size H1,
W1, D1, and you're performing
a convolution with a filter,
then the output, W2,
would be related to W1
with the following formula.
So W2 plus W1 minus filter width
plus one, and the same formula
applies for the height, and
the depth would actually
be the same because
in that case,
we're using a filter that
has the same depth, or three,
as the original image.
So what this would
produce in aggregate
is if you have 28 by 28 by one
neurons, each one performing
a dot product on some pixels
in the original image,
the output would be an
activation map of size 28 by 28
by one, and the
output of each neuron
would be one pixel in
the activation map.
Now, if we go back to the
points that we made earlier,
one thing we said was that the
reason you use a neural network
is because you don't know
exactly what features
you want to extract,
and you don't actually
have specific filters that you
want to apply to the image.
So ideally, what
you want to do is
have multiple filters being
applied to the first image,
and perform multiple
convolutions,
and this is what you can do
with multiple neuron layers.
So what we described before
was just for one neuron layer.
In that case, we can assume
we have five different neuron
layers, each one performing
a different convolution
on the original image.
So in that case, we
would have 28 by 28
by one neuron per
layer, and then
if we aggregate all
these neurons together,
we need to multiply
it by five, and that
would be the total
number of neurons we
have in that specific number.
So this actually leaves us with
a pretty complicated system.
It would have many parameters.
The neurons have weights,
the number of neurons
is also a parameter So how do
we actually formalize that?
If we have an input volume
of 32 by 32 by three, which
is our original image,
and a filter size of five
by five by three, then the
size of the activation map
that would be reduced
would be 28 by 28 by one.
Then in that case, we also said
we have five different neuron
layers that perform five
different convolutions.
Then the total number of neurons
would be 28 by 28 by five,
and then the weights
per neuron are five
by five by three, which is 75.
In that case, we're assuming
that the neurons independently
keep track of their own weights.
This could be simplified
to each layer having
their own weight, which
would tremendously reduce
the number of parameters.
But in that case, just
to get an upper bound,
this leaves us
with a total number
of parameters of 294,000.
And this is just using a
32 by 32 by three image.
You can think of this
as a pretty small image.
So if you have a
bigger image, you
will have many more parameters.
Great.
So what we just saw now, and
described, were convolutions,
activations, and these
steps happen sequentially
in a convolutional
neural network,
specifically as can be see here.
One step that also happens
occasionally is subsampling,
and we'll discuss that
step in detail here.
So there are two main reasons
why you would actually
subsample your input.
One is to obviously reduce
the size of your input,
and your feature space,
but also because you
want to keep track of the
most important information,
and get rid of everything
else that you don't think
is going to be relevant
to your classification.
And the common methods
used in subsampling
are either max pooling
or average pooling.
We will describe
max pooling here.
So what happens
in max pooling is,
essentially, you are
dividing the image
into different sub images,
non-overlapping sub images,
and you perform an
at max operation.
So in that case, if we
consider two by two filters,
we would split the image, which
in that case is four by four.
We'd split it into
four sub images,
and for each two by two square,
we would take the maximum.
In that case, for the first
square it would be six,
then eight, then
three, then four.
And the reason
that actually works
is because what you want
to do is really keep
track of the response of the
neurons that-- or the highest
response produced
by your neurons.
In that case, for example,
the first highest response
in the first square
is six, and that
means that if you get
that high of a response,
it means that something has
been detected in the image,
or has been detected.
And this is something you
want to keep track of as you
move forward in your network.
And although this moves
around the location of pixels,
because you can think of
that as subsampling an image,
it does keep track of the
information you care about
because you only
care about the fact
that something has been
detected in the image.
At this point, you
don't really care
about where it's
located in the image,
and you want to keep
track of all the features
that your neurons have
detected in order to be
able to eventually classify
the input correctly.
So if you have multiple
feature maps-- so in that case,
if you have 224 by 224 by 64,
what your subsampling operation
would be doing is reducing
the height and the width
so the depth would
remain unchanged.
So in that case, you would go
from 224 by 224 by 64 to 112
by 112 by 64, and that would
be reducing your output size
by a factor of four.
And formally, what
this would look
like is if you have
an input of size H1,
W1, D1, the size of
your output would
be related to your input
in the following ways.
W2 would be W1 minus
the pool width plus one.
The same applies for H2, and the
depth would remain unchanged.
So these are, essentially--
these are the steps that happen
in a convolutional neural
network.
What you could be doing
is repeating these steps
on a certain number of
times in your network.
But eventually, you have
to make a classification,
and decide in our case,
whether our image has a chair
or doesn't have a chair.
So how does that happen?
So after you perform
all these steps,
there's a step that happens
here that would allow
you to make that
prediction, and that step
is usually called a
fully connected layer,
or a multi-layer perception.
And what this essentially is is
layers that are very similar,
or exactly the same as
what you had before,
except that every
neuron in the layer
is connected to all
the previous neurons.
So what it's allowed
you to do is really
consider everything
you currently
have about your input,
or everything that's
left about your input, and
compute a dot product on that,
rather than focusing on a
subset subsample of your input
like previous layers do.
In that case, if
you're actually trying
to classify your input
into four classes,
you would ideally have
four different neurons
in your output layer,
each one corresponding
to one of the classes
that you have,
and then you would
perform the same operation
as you would in a previous
layer, compute the dot product,
and then once you obtain
the values at every neuron,
you would perform a
normalization operation
on all the output.
This organization operation
is called softmax,
or normalized exponential,
and what it does is really,
put more weight on
the highest value.
And by computing the
softmax at the output,
you're able to compute the
posterior probabilities,
and allows you to
make a more informed--
or basically make
a classification
decision on your input.
Great.
So that's everything.
And now, the next step will be
talking about back propagation.
ISHWARYA ANANTHABHOTLA: OK.
So now that Henry has
given us an overview
of the entire
architecture of a CNN,
I'm going to quickly
spend some time,
and talk about standard
preprocessing tricks and tips
that people might use
on the image dataset
before they actually feet
it through a neural net
to classify the images.
So let's suppose we
have a dataset x,
and there are n number of
data points in the dataset,
and each point has
a dimension, D.
So they have D
features per point.
So in this example, we use
these graphs as an example.
Basically, our original data
here has just two dimensions,
and it spans this
range of values.
So for example, if we want
to center this data, what we
would do is a mean subtraction.
So we basically
subtract the mean
across all the features
of all the points,
and we basically center it, and
you can see that transformation
here.
And then we might, again, go
for normalizing the dimension
so that you have it.
The data points
span the same range
of values in both dimensions.
So you can see that
transformation,
and how it's taken place here.
And we just divide by the
standard deviation to do this.
Something that's
very commonly done
is called PCA, or Principal
Component Analysis.
And the idea here
is sometimes we
have a dataset that has a
very, very high dimensionality,
and we would like to
reduce that dimensionality.
So basically, what
our goal is is
to project the higher
dimensional space onto a lower
dimensionality space by taking
the subset of those features.
And if you've seen
a little bit of 1806
from linear algebra,
the way we do
this is by generating
a covariance matrix,
then doing the single
variable decomposition.
And I'll gloss over the math
now, but that's the idea.
And you can see here
how the original data
spanned two dimensions.
I would decorrelate it so that
it spans a single dimension.
And even with this
data, you might
want to ensure
that it's widened,
which is the same deal.
You want the values to span the
same range in both dimensions.
So then you would just
divide by your Eigenvalues
to get the widened data.
This last bit is
something that's
very commonly done
as a preprocessing
trick, though people aren't
entirely sure why it works very
well, or that it
really does help,
but it's something
that people do,
and it's called
data augmentation.
So basically, if I
have a dataset that
contains a bunch of
images of chairs,
a bunch of images of tables, and
then a bunch of images of say,
trees, I might want to
intentionally augment
that dataset further by
introducing a few variations
on these same images.
So I might take the chair
image, rotate some, reflect it
a few more, scale, crop,
remap the color space,
or just kind of
have a process that
does this randomly
to create more
variation on the same dataset.
And this is a good illustration
of why this makes a difference.
I've taken an image
here of what looks
like a waterfall or
some spot of nature,
and simply just
inverted the colors.
And what I see, if I were to
just see this image alone,
it maybe looks like a
curtain, or a bit of texture,
or something.
And the idea is even
to a human perception,
these images have two
very different meanings,
and so it's interesting
to see what effect they
would have on a neural network.
And with that, we'll go over to
image classification results.
ALI SOYLEMEZOGLU:
So, so far we've
seen how convolutional
neural networks are built,
and certain image
processing techniques
we can use on the input images
to get them into formats that
are there for the
classification process,
but so far, it seems
a bit abstract.
It's good to know how CNNs work,
why CNNs work, but why don't we
take a look at some of the
practical results from CNNs,
and what they're used
for so that when you're
done watching this
lecture, you can
go home, and try classifying
images on your own time?
With that, let's first revisit
the ImageNet competition.
I hope you remember the graph
at the bottom from the beginning
of the lecture,
where we used this
to motivate the use of CNNs.
CNNs came onto the
picture in 2012,
but the winning CNN from 2012
was used on the 2010 ImageNet
competition as
well, and it managed
to bring down the top five
error rate to 0.17, which
is pretty much on the same level
as how performed in the 2012
competition when it was first
used, which was at 0.16.
So this just goes to show that
these convolutional neural
networks are the state of the
art when it comes to image
classification, and
that's why we're currently
focusing on that.
But you might be wondering
what the ImageNet
competition exactly looks like,
what the images looks like.
So why don't we
take a look at that.
As you can see here,
these are images
from the ImageNet competition.
Underneath each image
is a bold caption, which
is considered to be
the ground truth,
or what the competition
believes to be
the correct classification
of the image.
Underneath that
ground truth, you
see a list of five
different labels.
Now, these five
labels are produced
by a convolutional
neural network,
and the different bars--
the different lengthened bars,
some pink and others blue,
represent how
confident the CNN is
that what it sees in that
image is that specific label.
As you can see in
certain examples,
the CNN is pretty confident in
that it has a correct answer.
For example, when we look
at the container ship,
it's pretty confident that
what's in that image is exactly
a container ship.
There are certain cases when it
doesn't get the correct label
on its first try, but it does
have in its top five labels.
For example, you can
see grill and mushroom.
Now, the funny thing
about the mushroom image
is that what it thinks
the image should
be classified as is agaric.
And if you don't know, agaric
is actually a type of mushroom,
and in fact, it's a
mushroom that image.
And it make sense that
their confidence levels
are pretty much the same.
Agaric is slightly-- it's
slightly more complex that what
it sees in the image is agaric.
But there are certain
cases when the CNN
fails to classify
the image correctly
in its top five levels.
This will be registered
as a top five error,
as you just saw in the previous
slide about the top error rate.
One example here on
this slide is cherry.
Now, the ImageNet
competition believed
that this should be
classified correctly
as cherry, even
though there's also
a Dalmatian in the background.
The CNN, on the other
hand, is pretty confident
that what it sees in this
image is the Dalmatian.
But if you look at some
of the other results
within the top five, although
it doesn't guess cherry at all,
it does guess certain
fruits that it
may think look sort
of like cherries
like grape or elderberry.
So the CNN does
actually pick up on two
different distinct
objects within the image,
but as a result of how it's
built, or its training set,
it ends up classifying
it as a Dalmatian.
But it goes to show you
that CNNs could also
be used not just as an
image classification,
but also as object detection,
which we do not touch up
on in this lecture at all.
So I'm not going to
go further into that.
Now, this is all fun and all,
but what about some real world
applications?
So this is a study that they
did at Google with Google Street
View house numbers, where
they used the CNN to classify
photographic images of house
numbers, as you can see here,
of certain examples of
these house numbers--
what they look like.
So what the CNN was
tasked with doing
was that it was supposed to
recognize the individual digits
within the image, and then
understand that it's not
just one digit that
it's looking at,
but it's actually
a string of digits
connected, and successfully
classified as the correct house
number.
This can be quite challenging,
even for humans sometimes
when the image is quite blurry.
You might not exactly know what
the house number exactly is,
but they managed to get the
convolutional neural network
to operate around
human operator levels.
So that corresponds to
around 96% to 97% accuracy,
and what that
enables Google to do
is that they can
deploy the CNN such
that the CNN automatically
extracts the house
numbers from the images online,
and uses that to geocode
these addresses.
And it's gotten to a point
were the CNN is successfully
able to do this process
in less than an hour
for all of the street view
house numbers in all of France.
Now, you might asking where
this could be useful for.
If you don't have access
a lot of resources
to actually do this
geocoding process where
you match latitude and
longitude to street addresses,
then your only resource might
be actually photographic images.
So you actually need
something, hopefully not human,
but some sort of software
that can do this successfully.
And so this is, for
example, a place
in South Africa,
a bird's eye view.
Not sure if you can
exactly see, but there
are these small numbers on
top of each of the houses.
All of these numbers were
extracted and correctly
classified using this
previously seen CNN.
Another example from robotics
is recognizing hand gestures.
So obviously, robots
come equipped with a lot
of different hardware.
They can sense
sounds, they can also
capture images of
their surroundings.
And if you're able to classify
what you see-- if the robots is
able to classify
what it sees, then it
can actually act upon it,
and take certain actions.
That's why it becomes really
helpful to successfully
classify the images.
So this is what they
did using hand gestures,
where there were five
different classes.
Each class corresponds to the
number of extended fingers.
So a, b, c, d, the top row,
corresponds to the same class.
They all have two
fingers sticking out.
The bottom row has three
So that's another class.
And they get the error rate
down all the way to 3%.
So 97% of the time, the
convolutional neural net
correctly classified
the hand gesture.
And you can use these
hand gestures then
to give certain
commands to a robot,
and it can train the CNN
to act upon something
else besides hand gestures.
For example, if it's in
some sort of terranean
and you train it
on certain images
that you might find
in nature, then it
can take those classifications,
and act upon it once it sees,
for example, a tree, or
some sort of body of water.
It's all thanks to
image classification.
Now, obviously, gestures
are not necessarily static.
You could be waving your
hand, and so that would
require a temporal component.
So it's not just an image
you're looking at, but a video.
And so if follows
that we can probably
extend image classification
into video classification.
After all, videos are just
images with an added component,
specifically time.
Obviously, the added
temporal component
comes with a lot of
additional complexity.
So we're not going to dive into
any of that, but in the end,
it comes down to the same thing.
You extract features
from the videos,
and you attempt to
classify them using
convolutional neural nets.
So why don't we look
at a study done, again,
at Google, where they
extracted one million videos
from YouTube, sports videos,
with somewhere between 400
to 500 different classes,
and they used CNNs to attempt
to classify these videos.
Now, they used
different approaches.
They used different
approaches, different tests,
different types of CNNs that
I'm not going to go into.
But as you can see
here, these are
certain stills from these videos
where the caption highlighted
in blue is what the
correct answer should be,
and underneath it,
the top five labels
that the convolutional
neural network producers.
The one highlighted
in green is supposed
to be the correct answer.
So you can see on all of these,
it gets it within the top five,
and for the most part,
within the top two,
and it's pretty confident
when it does get it correctly.
Now, when I said that they use
different types of classifieds,
some of them were more
stacked classifieds,
where they were just trained
on stills within these images,
while others were what they
called fusion ones, where they
sort of add the temporal
component by fusing
in different stills from
these photo images together.
Now, the current accuracy rate--
the best one they've
achieved so far--
has been around 80% accuracy
within the top five label.
Now, 80% accuracy
is nowhere near what
we saw with the
ImageNet classification,
where in 2015, they had
managed to get it up
to 98% or 99% accuracy.
But obviously, there's way more
complexity involved in this.
So it makes sense that
it's not quite there yet.
But it does provide a good
benchmark, and something
to improve upon in
the future as well.
Now, that being said,
convolutional neural networks
do come with
certain limitations.
They're not perfect.
And so Julian will now
talk about the limitations.
JULIAN BROWN: Thanks, Ali.
So Ali talked about the
ImageNet competition,
and talked about how
the recent winners have
been convolutional neural nets.
So before, the best was about
26% top five error rate,
but now they've
actually gotten it
down to a 4.9% top five
error rate, and that
was-- the winner of that
competition, the 2015 one,
was actually Microsoft.
They've got the current state
of the art implementation,
and so because it's the
ImageNet competition,
that means they can
identify exactly 1,000
different categories of images.
So there are few
problems, actually,
with the implementation,
or just in general
with convolutional neural nets.
So one of them is that
1,000 categories, well, it
may seem like a lot--
ImageNet is actually one of
the largest competitions--
that's not actually
that many categories.
So it doesn't contain things
like hot air balloons,
for instance.
So these things that children
would be able to classify,
the neural nets actually
aren't able to, even
in the biggest competition.
And each of these
categories also
requires thousands
of training images,
whereas you could
show a child a couple
examples of a dog
or a cat, and they'd
be able to, generally, get a
feel for what a dog or a cat
looks like.
It takes thousands of images
per category for the neural
nets to learn, which means
that the total number of images
you need to train for
the ImageNet competition
is over a million.
And so this leads to
very long training times,
even with all of the
heavy optimizations
that Ishwari was telling
us about like how
efficient convolution
is, it still
takes weeks to train on multiple
parallel GPUs working together
to train the net.
There's actually a more
fundamental problem
with neural nets as well.
So here on the left, we have a
school bus, some kind of bird,
and an Indian temple.
And all of these
images on the left side
are actually
correctly identified
by convolutional neural nets.
But when we add this
small distortion here
in the middle, that doesn't
change any of the images
perceptively to the
human, this actually
causes the neural network
to misclassify these images,
and now all three of
them are ostriches.
So that's a little weird.
How does this work?
How did we find
those distortions.
So here on the left side, we see
how a neural network typically
works.
You start with some
images, you put it
through the different layers
of the neural network,
and then it tells you
a certain probability
that it is a guitar,
or a penguin.
So it classifies
it, and so we can
use a modification
of that method
by applying an
evolutionary algorithm,
or a hill-climbing or
gradient ascent algorithm.
We take a couple of images,
and we put them through,
it classifies it, and we see
what the classification is.
And then we can do some
crossover between the images.
So we take the ones that look
a lot like what we're training
for in the guitars or
penguins, in this case,
and we take the
features of those
that identify very
strongly as a guitar,
and we combine those together
in the crossover phase.
This is for the
evolutionary algorithm.
Then we mutate the images,
which is making small changes
to each one, and
then we re-evaluate
by plugging it back in
through the neural network,
and only the best
images, the ones
that looked the most
like a guitar or penguin,
are then selected for
the next iteration.
And this continues until you get
to a very high identification
rates, even higher than
actual images of the objects.
So using gradient ascent, these
are some of the images that you
could produce if you start
with just a flat grey image,
and then you run it
through this algorithm.
So here on the side,
we have a backpack,
and we can actually
see the outline of what
looks like a backpack in there.
And over here, we have what
looks like a Windsor tie
right here, but all of
these objects-- and perhaps,
there are things in
these other images,
but they seem to be lost in
the LSD trip of colors here.
So that's kind of strange.
That's definitely
not how humans do it.
So let's try a different method.
What if instead of
directly encoding,
which is where we change
individual pixels,
what if we change
patterns in the images,
like different shapes?
Then this is the kind
of output that we get.
So in the upper left,
we have a starfish.
So you can see that it
has the orange and blue
of the orange in the
starfish, and also
the blue of the ocean
of the environment
that typical images of
starfish are taken in.
And you can also see that it has
the points, the jagged lines,
the triangles that we associate
with the arms of a starfish.
But the strange thing
here is that they're not
arranged in a circular pattern.
They're not pointing
outwards like this,
like we would expect
of an actual starfish.
So clearly, it's not latching
onto the same large scale
features that humans do.
It's actually just looking
at the low down features.
Even though it's a
deep neural network,
it doesn't grab onto
these abstract concepts
like a human would.
So the reason for this
problem, or at least
why we think neural
networks aren't
as good as humans at things
like this is the type of model.
So a human would
have more of what's
called a generative model,
which means if we have examples
here, these dark blue
dots, say, of lines,
a few examples of
images of lines,
then we could construct a
probability distribution,
and say that images that
fall somewhere in this region
are lines.
And over here, we have a few
examples of giraffes, say,
and so anything that falls in
this region would be a giraffe.
And so if you had a red triangle
in here, that would be a lion.
But if the red triangle
is instead over here,
it actually wouldn't
classify at all.
We wouldn't know what that is.
We would say that's something
other than a lion or a giraffe,
but neural networks
don't work the same way.
They just draw a
decision boundary.
They just draw lines between
the different categories.
So they don't say that something
really far away from the lion
class is necessary not a lion.
It just depends how far away it
is from the decision boundary.
So if we have the red
triangle way over there,
it's very far away
from giraffes,
and it's just
generally closer lions,
even though it isn't explicitly
very close to it at all,
and that will still be
identified as a lion.
So that's why we think
we're able to fool
these neural networks in such
a simplistic way or in such a
really abstract way.
So the main takeaways
from our presentation,
and the salient points
are that deep learning
is a very powerful tool
for image classification,
and it relies on multiple
layers of a network.
So multiple processing layers.
Also CNNs outperform
basically every other method
for classifying images, and
that's their primary use
right now.
We're currently
exploring other uses,
but that's generally
where it's at,
and this is because
convolutional filters are just
so incredibly powerful.
They're very fast
and very efficient.
Also back propagation is the way
that we train neural networks.
Normally, if you were to
train a neural network that
has a lot of layers, there's
actually an exponential growth
in the time it takes to train
because of the branching when
you go backwards because
each neuron is connected
to a large number of neurons
in the previous layer.
You get this exponential growth
in the number of dependencies
from a given neuron.
By using back
propagation, it actually
reduces it to linear time
to train the networks.
So this allows for
efficient training.
And even with back
propagation and convolution
being so efficient, it still
takes a very large number
of images, and a long time
with a lot of processing power
to train neural networks.
Also, if you'd
like to get started
working with neural
networks, there
are a couple of really nice
open source programming
platforms for neural networks.
So one of them that we used
for our pset was actually
TensorFlow, which is Google's
open source neural network
platform, and
another one would be
Cafe, which is Berkley's
neural network platform.
And they actually
have an online demo
where you can plug in
images, and immediately
get identifications.
So you can get started
very quickly with that one.
Thank you.